how many kids you have five five yeah
five kids and we live in Manhattan so
it's like it's not like yeah it's not
like there's a backyard did you get the
kids a separate apartment so that that's
that's a good idea I mean you know a lot
of bedrooms I mean you got a big there's
a fair amount we used to be in a two
bedroom right with all our kids maybe a
year ago we were in the two bedroom
because shouldn't they say that the
healthiest thing is they need their own
bedroom they need their own space that's
ridiculous I mean you know the building
we lived in with two kids it's like
there was a family upstairs from China
that had like 30 people in it yeah they
look at you like you have a lot of space
yeah no it's it's I mean all our
ancestors were living in like a single
room and they were with their
grandparents so you're gonna make your
kids live in one room some of it is
they're so young look I do I want would
it be great to have a yard but I I need
New York and I also want my kids to be
New Yorkers but you were raised in
Indiana I know yeah so like you'd think
you'd want the wide open spaces no I
don't I don't even like going outside oh
this is okay with you being barricaded
in there absolutely yeah when you have
that much distraction at home can you
carve out time to work on your act I
imagine your wife looks at and goes hey
you're home you can you can just help
out and do something you say no no I'm
sitting here thinking about my act and
I'm writing jokes I mean I write
everything with my wife by the way so
yeah so we write everything together but
that's some of the crisis of Summer you
know it is a comedy writer yes we write
everything together when you met her yes
you just ran into her in some coffee
shop or something yeah in a Korean Deli
in our neighborhood how do you pick up a
woman like I would be so intimidated I
could never go up to a woman walking out
of a grocery store and go hey hey baby
yeah no I didn't have that confidence
until I was like 33 and then I did have
that confidence you saw her and you just
walked up to him and hey baby I said hey
do I know you and she said yes we've met
before like in the neighborhood yeah and
I said oh that's so weird and I said you
know we're probably going to get married
and then um you should have said you
know we're probably gonna have five kids
well I think I think I said we're
probably gonna have six kids in some
other discussion in a room I didn't
think we were actually going to have
five right but then uh she left and then
I went up to another woman I said hey
baby hey baby let's have five kids and
live in a one bedroom apartment yeah
yeah I'm a prize but it is hard writing
especially uh when Summer's out because
you know I guess who doesn't need a
three-month break after kindergarten
because it's so hard they just sit at
home like they've just gotten done like
fighting Isis like what are you gonna do
for me now yeah you know we spent the
whole year learning crayons I'm not sure
what's going on so how does that work
with your wife you guys are at home yes
do you treat comedy writing like it's a
nine to five kind of job do you sit down
and go today's Monday it's 9 A.M let's
start writing uh I try sometimes but it
doesn't work like that because she's
also my wife so she's like I'm I'm
trying to get them in a camp right now
foreign